Find the sum.
Express the answer as a
simplified rational
expression, and state
the domains.
We have these two rational
expressions, or two fractions,
if you will.
And whenever we add fractions,
we need to find a common
denominator, and the common
denominator has to be
something that's divisible by
both of these denominators.
In general, we want to find
the least common, or the
smallest, multiple of these
numbers, or the smallest
number that's divisible
by both.
When you look at it immediately,
it might pop out
at you that 6 is divisible by
3, and x to the fourth is
definitely divisible by x
squared, so 6x to the fourth
is definitely divisible
by 3x squared.
Of course, it's divisible by
itself, so this actually is
the least common multiple-- this
is the smallest number,
or the smallest expression, I
guess, that is divisible by
both 6x to the fourth and 3x
squared, so let's make that
the common denominator.
So this sum is going to be
equal to 5 over 6x fourth
plus-- and now, what we want
to do is write this with 6x
fourth as the denominator, so
let me just write it again.
So plus 7 over 3x squared.
So how do we make a 3x squared
into a 6x to the fourth?
Well we're going to have to
multiply it times 2 to make
the 3 into a 6, and then we're
going to have to multiply it
times another x squared, so
we're going to have to
multiply it by 2x squared.
Now we can't just multiply only
the denominator by 2x
squared-- that'll fundamentally
change the value
of this expression.
We can only multiply it by 1,
so let's multiply it by 2x
squared over 2x squared-- and
we're assuming here that is x
is not equal to 0.
x does not equal to 0.
And that was actually a safe
assumption to make, that 0 is
not a member of our domain right
from the get go, because
that would've made either of
these expressions undefined.
If we assume x is not equal to
0, we can multiply by 2x
squared over 2x squared, and
then that will give us the
expression 5 over 6x to the
fourth, plus-- this become 7
times 2 is 14.
Fourteen x squared over 3 times
2 is 6, x to the squared
times x squared is x to the
fourth, so now we have a
common denominator.
The common denominator is 6x to
the fourth, and we can just
add the numerators, so it's 5
plus 14x squared-- or, I like
to write the higher degree
term first-- or 14x
squared plus 5.
And we are assuming that x does
not equal 0, because this
would make the expression
undefined.
That's about as simple as we can
make it-- we can't divide.
14 is divisible by 2, and so
6, but 5 isn't, so we can't
divide everything by 2, and
then, there's x squared x to
the fourth, but 5 has no x term
on it, so we can't divide
everything by x or
a power of x.
We're done: it's 14x squared
plus 5 over 6x to the fourth,
and x cannot be equal to zero.